despite heavy pressure from the United
States and Israel 128 countries at the
United Nations voted to reject Donald
Trump's decision to recognize Jerusalem
as Israel's capital and move his embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem Israel called
those countries puppets and said its
capital would always be Jerusalem this
week my guest is Mark Regev
the former Israeli government spokesman
now his country's ambassador here in
London over the many years since Israel
annexed East Jerusalem what kind of city
has it become
[Music]
Margrave welcome to Concord zone thanks
for having me
128 countries rejected the u.s. decision
to remove its embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem your ambassador at the United
Nation labeled those 128 countries
puppets and your government called the
UN the House of Lies benefit these
insults bring you the truth is the UN
has a pattern of the historic bias
against my country and it's not unusual
if you get these massive majorities
against Israel I gratuitously insulting
comments well I think the UN deserves to
be criticized for its treatment of
Israel what countries like China Russia
India France Great Britain that voted
the way you don't like to be called
puppets I would remind you that
consecutive Secretary General's of the
United Nations the current one and the
two previous ones have all called out
the UN as an institution of having a
bias an obsession with Israel and there
is a serious problem there that has to
be dealt with but these countries just
don't agree with the alternative
universe that your government
constructed for itself dude no no I
think anyone who looks at the UN pattern
of Israel the way people vote in the
General Assembly I mean more resolutions
passed condemning the only democracy in
there in the Middle East in condemning
North Korea or Syria Saddam's Iraq
talked about the extension see a little
later but there is a pattern of
institutional bias which has to be
called out anyone who believes the
United Nations has been fair on Israel
needs to look at the past
Germany ballistic azusa France Russia
China are they were biased against
Israel would you like to look at the
substance of the discussion which is
could you answer the question do you
think they're biased against Israel I
see anxious I think president Trump's
decision was a good decision and that
more countries question you lump them
all into the house of law permits these
countries they you is
as an institution is biased the
institution is made up of individual
countries I'm asking you whether those
individual countries are biased those
individuals eroded you don't seem to
wonder answer the question no I won't
say the the those UN countries voted the
wrong way but are they biased against
Israel therefore there is a pattern of
institution you're not saying this our
year after year in the United Nations
you don't want the soundbite being
recorded that you say that Britain and
France and Germany and Russia and China
look at the say that why don't we look
at the countries they're not gonna say
why don't we look at the countries who
who refuse to support this Canada
Australia very few Holland Republic very
few the moral minority very few you're
clutching at straws the truth is though
if you look at patterns of voting at the
UN you'll actually see that many
countries the automatic majority that's
often against Israel has actually over
the last few years being slowly but
surely depleted and I am confident that
that process will continue
well isn't doing very well as far as
you're concerned in Britain is it
because the British government response
was Jerusalem was not your capital and
yours alone Alan Duncan at the Foreign
Office laid it out quite clearly he said
we do not agree with the announcement
that Jerusalem is the capital it should
have been a final status issue in
particular of course Jerusalem is
divided between East and West Jerusalem
and East Jerusalem is most certainly not
part of Israel so you're not having much
luck at changing the British
government's position when diplomacy is
is not about insisting in diplomacy is
about talking and I'm hopeful and that
eventually Britain will recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel and
move its embassy there you say it's not
about insisting your Prime Minister once
Washington has announced his decision he
hopped on a plane to Brussels and tried
to strong-arm the European Union into
doing the same thing that's what we
think everyone should do the same thing
because I ultimately to recognize we
don't see the world as you see it they
don't see Israel as you see can't you
accept that I wouldn't use that language
I told them it was time they recognized
the facts that a strong army strong but
now I think I think it is the fact that
the truth is Jerusalem has been the
capital of this
of Israel since 1949 it's been the
capital of the Jewish people for some
3,000 years anyone who denies the Jewish
connection to Jerusalem denies reality
yeah and there been a lot of unpleasant
realities that have been worth denying
over the years so there's nothing
unpleasant about Jerusalem being the
capital of Israel it's a city that we
cherish well Duncan said it quite
clearly didn't he he said it's not your
capital Jerusalem is divided between
East and West Jerusalem East Jerusalem
is most certainly not part of Israel you
can't get it much clearer than that but
if the opinion of some in the
international community that everything
over the 67 line is open for negotiation
then I've asked the following question
Jerusalem was Israel capital not for
1967 from 1949 what is the problem in
recognizing Jerusalem as Israel's
capital it's recognizing a reality well
if you talk to the British government
which I assume is you're wrong rather
then you will know exactly what the
problem was because they've told you and
I disagree with their analysis yeah and
so it's not going anywhere is it I mean
this this is part of the Trump playbook
that your government is using isn't it
you reject all criticism you double down
on whatever actions cause that criticism
in the first place don't you no but when
criticism is unjustified I think it's
within our right to stand up and say we
disagree with the criticism you don't
care what the rest of the world thinks I
mean that's not true on the country your
Public Security Minister Gilad erdan
came out and said it at the end of last
month
plain unequivocal language to the
Central Committee of your ruling liquid
party you remember what he said no
reminder well it's good that I can
inform you of one do you think we're
telling the world it doesn't matter what
the nations of the world say the time
has come to express our biblical right
to the land so that's it the time for
negotiation is over as far as the
government's concerned I would say the
following my Prime Minister's this week
as you know in India on a historic trip
which voted against the which rejected
Trump's move last year he was in Latin
America in Africa in Europe we believe
that Israel's case is strong and we're
making that case internationally and I
think you'll see more and more countries
coming around to supporting the way
Israel looks are you telling me you
repudiate what the Public Security
Minister has said once again if he's
saying that we
they right no he's saying we're telling
the world it doesn't matter what the
nations of the world say that makes your
diplomacy rather useless doesn't it I
think the most important half I believe
in the essential justice of my countries
cause of Israel's cause and I will
continue to make that case be helpful if
you talk with one voice then wouldn't it
instead of one minister going out
publicly and saying no we're not
interested in what the rest of the world
is we had a system as in North Korea we
would speak in one voice but as you know
Israel is democracy our governments our
coalition speaker metrically opposed
position I wouldn't overstate that but I
think anyone as you know who's covered
Israeli politics know that there's
always a divergency of opinions in the
Israeli political elite which I suppose
is healthy and is has been for some time
correct like the your former Attorney
General Michael Ben yeah who put it in a
few years back we're talking about
Israel he said we enthusiastically chose
to become a colonial society ignoring
international treaties expropriating
lands transferring settlers from Israel
to the occupied territories engaging in
theft and finding justification for all
that activity differences I'm very proud
to live in a country where people can
openly criticize government policy our
country whether it's written to the
press of free trade unions of free
academic institutions and I think Tim to
be fair I think Israel is the only
Middle East country a crucial point
which is Israel is an open free
tolerant liberal pluralistic society and
for all those things I think my country
should gets a certain amount of credit
Daniel Seidelman who's director of the
group Terrestrial Jerusalem they're
examining what Jerusalem might look like
under a two-state solution he went even
further he said what was winked and
nodded about before is now being
acknowledged publicly we you means
Israel have no intention of sharing this
land with anybody else except as a
barely tolerated minority so this is
where you've got to that's the future
assessment and that that's not the
position of Israeli government perhaps
you could explain how the position of
the Israeli government squares with the
notion of Israel's Declaration of
Independence which said pledged to
ensure complete equality of social and
political rights to all its inhabitants
irrespective of religion race or sex
you've never done that in 50 in the
country
on the country in since Israel's
independence in 1948 all Israeli
citizens have equality under the law is
Rayleigh citizens it doesn't say that
says inhabitants of Israel irrespective
of religion race or sex that's hundred
percent correct all inhabitants of
Israel have equality under the law and
I'm proud to say that I live in the only
country which guarantees legal equality
under the law that's why you have
consistently refused to address the
glaring discrimination against Israeli
Arabs that successive reports both from
your own government commissions and from
your friends at the US State Department
have highlighted last January Human
Rights report from the State Department
said institutional and societal
discrimination against Arab citizens of
Israel goes on in particular in access
to equal education housing and
employment opportunities how does that
square with your dekhta so I would agree
that Israel we've made a commitment to
equality about our citizens and it's
crucial that we we act in a proactive
way through affirmative action to narrow
those gaps but you haven't in the last
30 years you've done nothing since since
the First Intifada when a judge led
commissioned the or Commission
determined that far from extending the
head of peace to Arabs as you always
like to say the State of Israel
according to the Commission did not do
enough or try hard enough to create a
quality for its own cities I think if
you look very closely at the budget
allocations over the last five six years
you'll see the government of Israel has
turned a corner that the investment in
the Arab sector whether it's in
infrastructure whether it's in education
whether it's in other social services is
there an all-time high
we are committed as a government not
just in word but in deed to narrowing
narrowing gaps with exist we will live
up to our commitment in our Declaration
of Independence of equality Cades have
gone by when you could have done so much
more and anti-arab discrimination has
continued in the same way in Israel to
the point where in 2014 your president
Reuven Rivlin labeled Israel sick with
racism and condemned the
including politicians who Stoke
anti-arab rhetoric and violence he said
I'm not asking if we've forgotten to be
Jewish I'm asking when first of all my
my president is expressing the moral
authority of my country
and whenever racism raises its ugly head
we will condemn it we will fight it we
will eliminate he was questioning
whether you're behaving like human
beings why do you think what what do you
think tempted him to even mention that
you don't hear many presidents when
asking whether they're behaving like
human business is not assigned to him
that Israel is a self-critical
introspective country where we debate
the issues we don't run away from
uncomfortable news we want to engage we
want to discuss to address anything
really you have only to listen to your
own State Controller and Ombudsman
September 2016 Judge Joseph Sabir
lambasted what he said whether minimal
activities of the education system to
support unity in Israel's society the
State of Israel is doing very little he
said this is in September 2016 years
after you say you're trying to do
something I'm doing very little to purge
the severe phenomena of racism and
hatred among youth and they're doing
very little he says look in all Western
countries in all countries racism
sometimes raises its ugly head the most
important thing what does leadership do
does leadership speak out against racism
delete it as leadership condemn racism
and when there are gaps in society as
there are in all societies our
governments committed to narrowing those
gaps and Israel the answer to that
question is affirmative let's look at
the city of Jerusalem under Israeli rule
it's become a place of division and
poverty predominantly for the Arab
sector in East Jerusalem the part you
occupied in 67 and then annexed
according to last year's poverty report
of the National Insurance Institute
three-quarters of the residents of East
Jerusalem and eighty three point four
percent of the children live below the
poverty line that's more than 50 percent
higher than the equivalent poverty rates
in the rest of Israel
you let it get so bad I think the most
important thing to remember is that
since Israel unified the city in 1967
for the first time in the history of the
city all communities have religious
freedom all the religious sites of all
the faiths are protected and that each
religious community autonomously
administers its own religious site so
the Christian religious I'm talking
about why they would in the in this how
the center hora will get an area Tech
Israelis we'll get to that in a second
but one has to look at the facts this is
a city that's important to millions of
people around the planet yes so let it
sing the religious sites of all faiths
are for the first time autonomously
administered by their own respective
religious communities that the freedom
of worship is enshrined in Israeli law
that is something that I believe is well
deserved credit for essentially you let
it gets over I come back to this
question which you don't want to answer
why did you let it get so bad I thought
actually if you look at the situation in
the Arab neighborhoods of the city
you'll see that there are gaps that need
to be narrowed but compare them to Arabs
in other parts of the Middle East or
even in the Palestinian territories you
see that they are considerably better
but let's look at some of those gaps
because your own human rights
organization bets elem points out while
Palestinians make up almost 40% of the
city's population the municipality runs
only six family health centers in their
neighborhoods six do you know how many
they run in the Jewish neighborhoods
tell me sir twenty-seven same story with
social services I know in the poor in
the Palestinian neighborhoods nineteen
in the Jewish neighbor do you think
that's fair
first of all the Arab population in
Jerusalem makes up about a third of the
paper of the city and it's important I
think that Arab Jews Lamont's receive
the same services as do as everyone else
taxes pay taxes I've heard directly from
the mayor of Jerusalem near Baraka he
said he's committed to narrowing those
gaps and I'd ask you once again to look
at the trajectory is he in fact is the
municipal government of ruling today
investing more in the Arab sector in
Jerusalem and I think the answer is
clearly yes and as that trajectory
continues you'll see gaps narrowed which
is what we committed to doing well this
is the mayor who in 2030
in the municipal elections only got just
over 500 votes from a maximum of a
hundred and fifty-seven thousand
Palestinians who could have voted for
him and surely that's a question that
the arab leadership that's what they
thought of his efforts no but let's be
clear if Arab residents of Jerusalem
utilized the the ability of the nor
Christine actually participated in new
civil elections maybe they'd have more
political on the political clout on the
council to actually get the bread and
butter issues that they maybe if you
gave them full status and equal status
with Israeli Jews they would feel like
having a stake in that society only
status as you know the only status open
to them in East Jerusalem is that of
permanent residence a status which
confers far fewer rights than
citizenship let's just stop for a moment
we have the Jerusalem arms in Jerusalem
have full rights to vote in municipal
elections not in national yes that you
were talking to me specifically your
question was about the mean the way the
municipal governor Jerusalem hands out
its resources that was what your
question was about surely the
Palestinians the Arab population of
Jerusalem would be doing itself a
failure a favor if it fully participated
in the democratic process they can't
fully populated by terrorist groups who
intimidate you today not one shred of
evidence to back that up I beg to
disagree wherever their groups like
Hamas Islamic Jihad and the other
extremist groups are not known for being
particularly tolerant about people who
have survived loans that's not evidence
let's say it's experienced another set
of restrictions on the pastor's living
in East Jerusalem is land according to
the Jerusalem Institute for Policy
Research the population density in
Palestinian areas is almost double that
of Jewish neighborhoods why and why in
these crowded neighborhoods do continue
to put in Jewish settlers in some 2800
settlers had moved into Palestinian
neighborhoods Bette Salem says the
settler in Claes have made the lives of
Palestinian residents unbearable forcing
them to contend with legal proceedings
aimed at driving them from their homes
invasion of privacy and daily harassment
I don't accept that analysis I accept
that it's our duty as a government and
then we've come to Jerusalem to make
sure that we are acting to narrow gaps
where they exist that you're not know I
disagreed you might argue with its
quickness in the health game you could
argue it's not as quick as it should be
only 52 percent have access to the legal
water grid in the Palestinian area once
again you talked about you talk about
water you're talking about a society
when the city was unified that was far
behind and and I agree that we have to
do more to narrow the gaps where they
exist but we're committed to doing so
very fast another feature of life in
East Jerusalem of the frequent raids by
your security forces on Palestinians
other than the dead of night one example
three months ago the night of October
22nd around 11:30 at night hundreds of
Israeli police border police special
patrol units raided the Palestinian
neighborhood of L as suya in East
Jerusalem according to bet Salaam the
forces entered dozens of homes arrested
51 residents including 26 years between
15 and 17 they were forced to sign a
declaration a statement of apparently of
what they'd said in Hebrew they don't
they can't write and read Hebrew why do
you do this so I don't have the
specifics on this I'm happy to get back
to when I found out exactly what
happened on that night I do know it's a
pattern though isn't it no it happens
repeatedly according to bed seminar the
human rights organize there is there is
a question of law and order if people
are involved in criminal activities it's
the job of the police to act against
them and as you know in some of these
areas which you quite quickly said where
there's more poverty you get gangs you
get violence and it's important that the
police act against these groups is why
they held why they picked up at the dead
of night once again I don't have the
specifics because I don't know what
exactly happened I don't know but often
when one arrests people you want to
arrest them when they're at home and
that means you come at night the
teenagers remain completely isolated for
the duration of the arrest without the
protection of their parents or another
adult they can trust and are cut off
from their families and daily lives
without knowing what's going to happen
to them do you think that's fair for
teenagers between 15 and 17 years old
all democracies have a dilemma to deal
with mine
when you're involved in violence when
they're involved in crime it's not never
an easy no country has a solution that
is perfect we own Israel of course
grapple how do you do how do you deal
effectively with minors involved in
crime hopefully we're doing a good job
doesn't sound like it does it they said
but Salaam says this reality of the
arrests and likely arrests this reality
is endemic to Israel system of control
and oppression of the Palestinian
population in these Jews once again the
the Arab population of Jerusalem has all
the legal rights as anyone else in that
city and anyone who really doesn't know
anyone who believe I've talked about the
national election it doesn't have the
right Israeli citizens voting is a
election Israeli citizens have taken out
Israeli citizenship can vote in our
elections if you choose not to take out
Israeli citizenship then you can't vote
in our elections that's clear I think
that's the lot of them just have
permanent residency don't they and I've
had a permanent residency for decade but
as they cannot vote in national election
you can't vote in municipal elections
and the truth is because of threats by
the extremist groups unfortunately most
of them still do not do so and I think
one should ask the extremists about
extremists why do you prevent encourage
intimidate Palestinian Arab residents of
Jerusalem not to vote in elections why
do you stop why do you stop people
coming into the country now who belong
to the boycott divestment and sanctions
movement who recommend an economic
boycott of Israel why are you stopping
them coming into the country now every
democracy on the planet has the right
and to what happens in this country
who's happens in the United States as
happens in now the European countries
has the right to prevent people from
visiting you are a counter to the common
good this is a freedom of expression she
was a violation of democratic principle
I'm sorry in Britain where we're
conducting this interview they're very
strict the home office of who can come
in and who can come out sorry who can
come into this country I recommend a
boycott of Britain if you like you
you're certainly I know it
it's the prerogative of the Home
Secretary to decide who can come into
this country or not this country is a
democratic country it Israel has the
same rights as other democracy it may be
the prerogative but it's losing new
important supporters I don't think these
people particularly supported us in the
first place let's take a man called
David Rothkopf who's a senior fellow at
Johns Hopkins School of Advanced
International Studies a Jew who lost
three dozen of his relatives and the
Holocaust a few days ago he wrote
banning those whose opinions are
uncomfortable for Israel to hear and
consider not only weakens the country
but suggests that the reasons for my
defenses of Israel are collapsing are
collapsing says the Netanyahu
administration has done more than ban
critics it has turned supporters into
adversaries it has taken one large step
in the direction of the liberal Fargo
crisis favored by the likes of Trump and
it's done something else he said it's
broken the heart of those who wish deep
within their DNA that Israel would have
lived up to be even a shadow of the
dreams our fathers and mothers had for
it you can spend tens of thousands
countering the BDS movement but if you
lose a man like that with his attachment
to Israel to Judaism with his
intellectual abilities you're in more
trouble than you think but I reject the
substance of his argument anyone who
goes to Israel and you visited my
country many times who reads the Israeli
press who follows the Israeli NGO scene
who sees the debates in our Parliament
who sees the debates in our in our
electronic media everyone knows that
Israel is a country with a speed of
speech and freedom of thought it's a
Crescenta country where the debates on
these political issues he doesn't and
many others but he I'm sorry he's wrong
anyone who visits Israel objectively
knows these I urge you just to go these
are the people mr. Ragab who you're
losing and you can ill afford to lose
people like that I'm sorry but I can
disagree with him if they're factually
wrong and he is factually wrong on this
particular case Israeli democracy is
strong and vibrant I mean I heard you
just to go to your computer and read a
dozen Israeli newspapers
criticism will you find of the
government when where else in the Middle
East do trade unions strike and can
close down the whole country where else
in the Middle East you have vigorous
debates in Parliament where government
policy is debated in politicians argue
with each other in an open way where
else in the Middle East you have
petitions being signed and
demonstrations we are a country with
faults but we are a vibrant pluralistic
Democratic Society and anyone who says
to the country is simply not telling the
truth mr. egg if it's been good to have
you on the program thank you very much
I think that
[Music]
you
[Music]